hey everyone this is Steve watch up with
Collider at the Collider media suite
media studio here at the kia telluride
supper suite in Park City Ron Howard
how are you today I'm good I'm glad you
could explain where we are this is my
first time in Sundance and it's real
yeah it's Sundance and it's kind of a
little bit of a blur but it's good to
see you well first of all you're here
for rebuilding paradise which is a
fantastic documentary thank talk a
little bit I I hate asking the generic
question but no one will have seen the
movie I just watching talk a little bit
about what it's about well on November
8th of 2018 a town in Northern
California of 26,000 people paradise
California a town that I knew because my
mother-in-law had lived there last four
or five years of her life and I visited
many times it was caught in the wake of
a giant forest fire and 95% of the town
burned as I said this is a town of
26,000 people it's not tiny 95% and you
know while I as a consumer of news like
most people you know look at these
images of catastrophes and I'm a little
bit numb you know and I did I feel
horrible and and I hope that never
happens to me and and then I go on with
my day this is paradise California a
place I knew couldn't really feel that
way about it and as imagine as our
documentary division has really grown I
felt you know maybe there's a story here
and it turned out to be my first
Veritate documentary which is to go to
paradise and tell the story of a
community in the wake of this kind of
crisis not the not only the immediate
wake of the crisis but to embed and
follow follow it for a year and so we
tell the story through the lens of a
number of individuals whose whose
personal story lines we began to follow
and and who basically demonstrated to us
just how complicated just how
emotionally and physically straining and
dangerous at times it can be and and it
was
one of the really remarkable experiences
of my life to be a part of it work on it
in post-production and as well as of
course being there I was gonna say one
of the things listen it hit me hard and
I think that you you mentioned the fact
is there are so many our new cycle moves
so quick that you know a day if the news
story stays in the news for like two
three days that means it's really dire
otherwise it's one day and done well you
know we this was a huge story across the
country and and and truly devastating
and and yes there was a tremendous
amount of of coverage and when I first
got there and began you know engaging
with the story you know it was still
crowded with journalists and so forth
but but in subsequent visits pretty
rapidly that fell off and I think that
the residents began to understand that
we we were telling a different story not
not just you know the drama of the event
but actually understanding what they
were going through and wanting to share
that with audiences
I thought the opening 10 minutes is
harrowing I was nervous while watching I
felt the anxiety so talked a little bit
about putting that opening 10 minutes
and why you wanted to open just right
immediately into the fire well because I
said this is a gym you know it's a human
interest story it's about following a
lot of individuals but you know in a
movie movie you would follow characters
after understanding what it is they did
endured you know you or you'd reveal it
later excuse me
with this we just needed to let people
understand not in a few wide shots and
some news footage but get a real
intimate sense of what it was like and
because we were then going to tell we
hoped
intimate stories of of people
endeavoring to to endure you know in the
wake of what winds up winds out to be
winds up to be a very cruel test so we
started you know our producers Ann
Parker was get one on Facebook and she
was reaching out to people anyone
willing to let us look at their cell
phone footage
I had conversations with police officers
and fired body about their body cam
footage that was unbelievably emotional
because this was their community as well
right there they're responding they're
doing their job they're giving
everything they have putting their lives
on the line and and yet you know we have
footage of an oven officer watching his
house burn through his body cam and our
dashboard cam actually and so we wanted
that kind of intimacy and intensity and
it's probably it's probably the most
intense scene you know that I've ever
been involved in you know emotionally
and visually also because you're
watching real life this isn't some it's
not backdraft yeah it it's it's you know
and you hear the voices of people and
it's mostly through their point of view
but again and occasionally during the
course of of the film we go back to that
kind of footage to remind audiences of
what these characters what these
individuals were following I went
through what they endured sure I'm
fascinated by the editing process
because that is the final rewrite did
you ever have a cut that was way longer
like oh yeah but by the way in Veritate
Doc's it's not it's not the final
rewrite I mean eventually it's the final
rewrite but it's also the first draft
because you know you you can't script
this you you you do research you learn
as you go but it's really the people
that you're interviewing and what you're
observing and what you can get on camera
that that that's that's that's the story
that's that's the script very unnerving
for a guy like me who spent an entire
lifetime
you know carefully trying to advance and
understand you know the screenplays to
build these moments and here it's all
about trusting the just this process of
discovery it's very different when you
get to the editing room it's similar
because now you have what you have this
raw material that you've gathered and
now you've got to tell the story in a
cinematic way a way that conveys the
ideas for audiences in a you know an
engrossing a compelling way and in this
case you
way that also I hope as you know
stimulates empathy under on a deep level
no a hundred percent did you have what
was like did you have a storyline or
something that came close to being in
the film that you ended up removing for
some reason like do you know what I mean
yeah well I mean there were there were a
number of individuals who we followed we
cast the net very wide Oh God
you know and then slowly but surely at
you know as the months went on we began
to understand you know who who we might
focus on more and narrow that and you
know it was interesting the I I think
what what very organically happened is
we were following the people who were
really really showing up the ones who
were engaging I mean many people were
devastated but they vanished they they
they were not there to fight for
rebuilding paradise so the individuals
that we kept revisiting in who very I
think courageously and graciously
allowed us into their lives you know
witnessing you know a lot of very
difficult and upsetting moments along
with some moments of real achievement
and growth but it that it it the lesson
that I learned was that you know that
that engagement is like one of the great
foundations for healing and and
certainly for growth in a community and
and because the the people who were
going to gold nugget days that's the
parade that they would have every year
you know they they wanted to put gold
nugget days on up and they did it it was
a shadow of what it had been but they
were their Christmas tree lighting town
council meetings memorials these things
matter and and if there's a lesson in it
just as a citizen it's it's pay
attention to your community your your
your community is not something to be
taken for granted it's something to be
nurtured 100 percent um there's no way
of getting around the fact that climate
change is a huge
there's nothing I say right now there's
not enough I can say climate change is a
huge problem around the world I look at
the Australian fires and it's all
interconnected well it you know
scientists tell tell us it is and I
believe them so did the firefighters
that we interview who were fighting the
fires they're confronted with this the
you know it's not like the town of
paradise had never had a fire before
they had it's not like the town of
paradise didn't anticipate that a really
bad fire could come through some day and
cause a lot of problems they did it had
strategies they had bid they had you
know plans in place but they were just
overwhelmed because none of it was
adequate
none of it could anticipate you know the
intensity of this particular fire but
it's not an outlier we're seeing it over
and over and over and you know and I if
there's if there is a message I suppose
it's this is a new normal and we have to
understand what it means to go through
it and by understanding that perhaps you
can anticipate perhaps you can prepare
on a governmental level and on a human
personal level before I run out of time
with you I definitely have to ask you a
few other things
I thought your daughter did such an
amazing job on the mandalorian oh I'll
pass that along right and so I do two
straight strange as it might seem dad's
proud right I have to ask you did she
show it to you early or did you watch it
when it first arrow I can now admit that
it's aired that yes I did I did get to
see it early and I even got to throw in
a couple of comments most most ignored
you know she is my daughter right you
know why would you why would you listen
to anything I say but I thought you did
a great job with the episode and and
learned so much and you know kind of
under the tutelage of Jon Favreau who's
got you know doing great work on that
show and is incredibly passionate about
and shows that a big success so Brice is
thrilled about that she also has a
documentary called dads were you in
Toronto did you have did you see I spoke
to her oh great
very very proud of that that that that
comes out around Father's Day and she
and so she's loved that now she's
getting ready for Jurassic world that's
that's for her year this year I have to
ask you have you obviously are a huge
Star Wars fan do you have any thought
about wanting to do an episode of
Mandalorian yourself or is it something
have you said to John hey you know this
is kind of good yeah it is good
yeah it is really good you know what
even this the solo situation as much as
I do love Star Wars and all things
galaxy
it's imagined is is so dynamic and
there's so much going on with imagine
entertainment and so many creative
opportunities that that I don't I don't
really have the time as much fun as it
would be something right now we are
developing willow for Disney plus Oh sir
that was a question coming and I don't
know about directing or not but I but
Jon Caston is writing he's very
passionate about it he's doing a great
job we don't have a green light yet but
if it goes I'll certainly you know want
to roll up my sleeves and be a part of
that because that would be a great to
revisit that world if you don't mind me
asking with something like when you're
developing a like a project like a
willow for Disney Plus are you do they
give you the idea of hey we want to do
six or eight episodes or we want to do
two two-hour movie like do they give you
that sort of outlining thing or you sort
of on your end thinking how do we want
to do it and then presenting it to the
studio what they tend to do is look to
the to the showrunner in this case
that's Jon cast and say how many hours
are you thinking and if that if that's
in alignment with their thinking fine if
not that it's a comment it's a
conversation but they they and you know
in this and in this this world of these
events series they really do look to the
the showrunners and the key creatives to
to tell them their vision these things
and it's one of the reasons why TV has
gotten so good is that they really are
looking at the showrunners as authors of
of something that they're they're deeply
passionate about and john is deeply
passionate about willow which tickles me
know in my last thing on willow um do
you have is it like after where the
movie took place do you have a timeline
he would shoot me but no well I mean
work Davis is going to be ended and so
you know yes I think it's safe to say
it's a it's a decades later if you could
add one category to the Oscars what
would you add oh I really like I like
what the
Grammy's do I like with the critic with
the film with the the Critics Choice
does
I like categories I honestly wish the
Academy did you know a sort of a
adventure sci-fi I or sci-fi horror I
wish they did a comedy category yeah you
know and then I wish the big playoff was
Best Picture so that you know Best
Picture could be a documentary it could
be an animated it could be so I wish
they were all you had five or six cats
onra categories and then and in sort of
the grand grand it's a gesture it's
interesting you say that because like a
comedy we'll never get to Best Picture
it's just never gonna happen and I don't
I don't maybe certain people just don't
realize how difficult it is to make a
comment at is a high-wire act of all
highwire acts but by the way I I you
know say what you want to say about
about you know superhero movies and so
forth those are incredibly difficult
movies to make and require you know
masterful direction it takes years of
planning and thoughts some of them are
more formulaic than others but when
somebody makes an original and expresses
themselves through that through that
genre that's his that's as legitimate as
anything I could not agree more are you
thinking about a comic book movie in the
future I don't have one but I wasn't a
comic book
you know reader when I was a kid so no
there's not one and that that that I
that I have I have a lot of projects
that I'm very interested in and I did
love given the circumstances of the way
I want to be involved in solo I had a
blast making that movie and it did
remind me that I really enjoy that that
kind of playful storytelling and and and
the action and and and I you know and I
love tech I love actors more but but you
know it's it's it's great what you can
offer audiences I'll say it on camera
and I thought you did a great job with
solo and the thing the thing that I have
found over the last few years is that
and I it wasn't this way when I was
younger but there is a toxics a toxicity
in fandom where people are like it's
just it's really bad
yeah and so I'm wondering like you
obviously took on Star Wars there are so
many people that love it and you're
always gonna have people that say oh no
that's
for me did that sort of turn you off to
that kind of a movie or did you sort of
say well this happens on every movie
well it doesn't happen on every movie
with that kind of intensity but it sort
of goes with the territory when you have
you know really high level intellectual
property you know there's a bit of that
when I did the grinch 20 and years ago
you know but but George Lucas is a
mentor a tremendous friend he he warned
me and he's always said hey look it's
for the fans and and yet you have to
have the courage to you know sort of
hear them but but but you know tell the
story you want to tell and and so he's
all for the galaxy expanding and
experimenting that's what he that's what
he prefers the most he gets most excited
about those that want to push the
boundaries of what a Star Wars movie or
TV show and he'd have always
contemplated TV shows of course he did
he made it so forth so you know I think
I think I was sort of prepared for it or
there's still a lot of deleted scenes
from that movie that have never been
seen I don't think so I think they
pretty much made it onto the the extras
because it was you know I mean given the
the circumstances with Phil and Chris
leaving the movie and me coming in it
was it was at a point where you know it
was it was it was almost a a rewrite and
a continuation and and then there were
there's a certain percentage of the film
that hadn't been shot at all yet so no I
mean I think we were pretty targeted as
to as to what we were what we were
making and so there's half scenes and
things like that but you can you can
find those sure if I'm not mistaken and
I make mistakes all the time you have a
movie coming out later this year
Hillbilly elegy for Netflix exactly we
should also have a theatrical run as
well we don't have a date yet but for
people that aren't familiar with it can
you say what it's about
it's memoir written by JD Vance it was a
best-seller for nearly two years and
it's about a guy from the Rust Belt Ohio
whose family came from
Appalachia Jackson Kentucky and it's a
sort of the collision between his
chaotic childhood and and sort of the
the way in which that informed his his
life and his thinking and and his and
his potential and which was ultimately
he graduated from from from Yale Law
School before he wrote this book and
he's going on to do other things and so
it's it's it's really a you know it's
it's a it's a story of transformation
and while it focuses on that culture a
group of people that I really really
relate to given my own family background
and history from and and my wife's as
well it's it really is about being your
best self finding strength in your
heritage and the lessons that you learn
but also recognizing the the hurdles
that some of that might represent as
well and and and learning how to grow
beyond it so it's just you know it's a
it's a self actualization story it's
it's it's powerful Glenn Close is
stunning plant your cast is ridiculous
Amy Adams just kills it and then we have
newcomers playing both a younger and
older JD Vance who did a you know a
great job as well
Haley Bennett's in and she's terrific
it's a it was a just a really great
performance opportunity probably the
best one that I've had in that regard
since maybe frost/nixon her beautiful
mind do you know if it are you guys
aiming for maybe like the Toronto Film
Festival with it I don't know I really
don't know
Netflix is marketing plans and because I
just finished we finished shooting
editing now as I was doing as I've been
doing rebuilding Paradise I've been sort
of dividing my time between hillbilly
ology editing rooms got a few pickups to
do and then we'll see see where they
what they do with it do you know what
your next film is gonna be after that I
don't know I've got a number of things
that I'm really working on films TV
series right where I'd like to do the
pilot or an event series where I'd like
to do the first couple of hours that
Lance Black is writing
that's under the banner of heaven based
on John Krakauer book really hope we get
to do that I don't know what's going to
fall into place so much going on with
imagine I have another documentary that
I'd like to do and you know Brian Grazer
and I are just having and having a blast
with you know all these projects we have
a a kids and family division yet imagine
now and they're doing great stuff and
including working on a tiny chef project
do you know tiny chef I don't but it
already sounds great do you tiny chef is
fantastic got you know the creatively
very rich time and imagine and I'm
really enjoying it the thing that I
found and I know we got to wrap up is
that uh this is an interesting time over
these next few years with all of these
streaming services all looking for
content so it's almost like imagined in
a perfect place in terms of you know
having the ability to push out content
to all the different places but we're
able to extend to some great
collaborators now artists some of what
imagine offers Brian and I in terms of
that sort of creative freedom and that
that possibility and then just finding
the story and then the perfect home for
it
you know what that NatGeo on rebuilding
paradise and many other projects that
we've done we're doing another season of
genius about Aretha Franklin and you
know these bold interesting projects and
NatGeo is the perfect home for them but
we have but we have you know projects
that you know all over who Disney Plus
and in Hulu and CBS all access and and
it's a it's really fun to find paramount
paramount network of 68 whiskey there's
a new show of ours and it's really work
you know and and again a great fit for
that Network so you get Roberto benebabe
who's a terrific showrunner had very
passionate about this show and we found
exactly the right home for it two last
things for you one you have an amazing
resume which do you think of your
previous films is going to be the first
to be rebooted huh well well well we're
talking about a splash with Amer man but
I don't know if it's really gonna happen
that's pretty experimental but Channing
Tatum is the one that wants to be
and so that's kind of a it would be fun
if that ever came together the first to
be rebooted well of course we have
rebooted right Friday Night Lights and
we're on the brink of doing a movie
again so we did a movie then it was a
show TV series excellent series it's one
of my all-time favorites very passionate
about a script that we have now for a
feature film version different set of
characters different part of the country
and the director can't announce but yeah
all going well and and very very
positive there I think it could be
shooting this year yes okay and
Parenthood was a movie then it became a
two series actually if one failed the
other one succeeded and there's talk of
Parenthood again as I'm possibly a movie
or possibly a Broadway musical and so
you know it's we're we're looking back
at our a lot of our projects my last
thing for you Bryce shared a great story
about wanting to shadow you on the set
of solo right to watch and learn
and she said she basically had to fight
to because you were a little
uncomfortable with that and so talk a
little bit my last thing and I know we
gotta go but like what was that like
having her with shadow she's not just
she's not really a daughter she's a
movie star you know and so with a young
cast feeling a lot of pressure on solo I
you know I I'm I wasn't necessarily sure
how everyone how comfortable everyone
would have with Bryce around but she
convinced me to try it for a day or two
and of course everybody fell in love
with her and because she's that kind of
that kind of person and and you know and
it was great having her around and and
she had a pretty couple of pretty good
suggestions yes God and did you use
those which I did Oh
unlike well listen I want to say again
how great of a job you do with
rebuilding paradise thank you um when is
it when can people see it it's we're
looking at a theatrical window spring or
summer and then fall and edgy Oh got it
listen I hope everyone Tunes in and sees
it thank you so much for visiting us
thank you to Kia and thank you to
everyone in Park City fun to see you
again